so before I saw this movie I thought the
whole team stark team cap thing was
bullshit
yeah I'm team Stark
I did not hit her it's not true it's
bullshit I did not hit her
I did not oh hi mark my eyes I didn't
miss anything that's what what time
Captain America
this version welcome back to my
hilarious ani segment it feels good to
be back
Captain America 1990 you know they tried
when I grew up superhero movies were in
a strange time period DC Comics had did
a great job with the first two
Superman's
and Batman made by Tim Burton but Marvel
kind of was like hey guys hey oh they
tried their live-action Spiderman show
which has a very young kid I loved but
you know let's admit it it's not very
good
they had some success with Lou Ferrigno
and Bill Bixby with their Incredible
Hulk show but pretty much everything
else they tried was an absolute disaster
the Fantastic Four movie in the 90s was
horrible all of the Captain America
movies up until that point were all
terrible and the 1990 version of Captain
America was atrociously bad in every
conceivable way it's like every choice
they made was an absolute atrocity my
fondest memory with this film in fact
the only fun memory that I have of it is
that I constantly saw that VHS tape for
rent at Blockbuster and I always picked
it up but I looked at it in like Captain
America looks cool and for some reason I
never saw it until now Steve Rogers in
this film is played by Matt Salinger I
don't know why because this is the most
uncharismatic Steve Rogers they could
have possibly had he has no energy to
him he's completely dull and lifeless he
is the most bland Captain America you
could possibly imagine
it's not until recently with movies like
Winter Soldier and civil war that
Captain America has really gotten a lot
more popular in the eyes of some fans
this is when Captain America was that
cornball cheesy idiot that we all loved
seeing Red Skull is the villain in this
film and the makeup is a thing of beauty
if it were oppositeday
he resembles a bloody turd a big crusty
hardened blood-soaked
piece of shit so you guys know the story
Steve Rogers back in the old days had a
girlfriend he really liked her he had
some problems he got turned into Captain
America and then he got attached to a
rocket somehow and got launched into
Alaska and a little boy saw this happen
and somehow was able to identify that on
this rocket up in the sky there's a man
on it and that boy grew up to be the
president and now an older more refined
version of the Red Skull who somehow
looks even more horrifying has kidnapped
the president and Captain America in
today's time has to find him that's the
plot of this piece of shit when I
watched this movie though I was excited
for one reason I was expecting some
awesome cheesy 1990 action set to some
horrible music with
god-awful sound effects and I've got
that but really not that much the
majority of this movie is like some
weird soap opera he meets the girl that
he used to love and she's old now and
she has a family that gets brutally
fucking shot what is he the majority
this movie is strange montage sequences
with horrendous music choices the entire
sequence where Captain America realizes
that he's in the future is hilarious I
laughed my ass off because it's like an
Adult Swim parody of Captain America
realizing that he's in the future
this memory
also Otis from Superman also known as
ned beatty is in this film I don't know
what the hell he was thinking he was
probably like I did a DC I'll do it
Marvel - oh shit let's go back to the
incredible lack of action this movie
really is like an elongated TV soap
opera with a couple random horribly
filmed action sequences with absurd
multiple cuts I mean I thought quick
cutting today was a problem look at this
shit it's the cheapest way of filming an
action scene let's get the guy to do
this role but oh shit the stunt guy it's
kind of dangerous we don't really have
that budget we'll just have them do like
the seven different takes and that'll
work right that's that's how you make a
movie right for an absurdly long portion
of this movie the biggest action
sequence that happens is he breaks
through the wall of a woman's restroom
and then when a sequence finally does
break out it's almost entirely in the
dark and you can't even see what's going
on during the big finale where Captain
America is trying to rescue the
president the part in the movie that I
laughed the most that happens the
president's like fuck you I'm jumping
off this cliff and he just jumps and
Captain America catches him and red
skull's reaction is the best
No
the final showdown between Captain
America and Red Skull is amazing this is
the movie I want to see this is right
here this is what I wanted the entire
thing to be like unfortunately the
majority of this movie is strange
montage sequences with 1980s music stuck
in a 1990 movie because they were in
this weird time period where they were
like wait is it the 90s yet or is it
still the 80s and of course I can't
forget to mention the most iconic part
of this movie is the president thanks
mr. president thanks so Captain America
defeats Red Skull and his henchmen by
throwing his shield and getting them
both in one go
and after this sequence I said to myself
wait a second did I just see what I
thought I saw
and I rewound it and I'm almost positive
that Captain America breaks the fourth
wall
I am absolutely convinced that he is
staring right at the audience are
horrified looks looking back at him and
he is thinking I am some cool ass shit
aren't I if that wasn't a hint at
breaking the fourth wall the very next
scene absolutely is where he turns
around and looks directly at us again
and can we please talk about the end
credits music except let's not actually
talk about it
I have the best insult for this thing
trust me I've thought about it this film
makes Fant for stick look good
OOP guys that's my hilarious year if
you've captain America in the 1990
version okay you know sometimes I like
to have fun in my reviews and I act
angry and I am angry but right now I
swear to you this film pissed me off
it's so terrible I mean there's nothing
redeeming about it Captain America is a
lifeless uncharismatic dull bland idiot
Red Skull looks like a bloody turd the
romance is boring it's a soap opera the
actions terrible it's so bad never watch
it ever guys thank you so much as always
for watching another hilarious 'ti I'll
have more retro rewinds and hilarious
ities coming your way very soon you guys
are the best and if you like this you
can click right here and get steppen
eyes
you